hey guys I'm back in st. Louis in the US
I arrived last night I actually slept
normally I feel a bit jet-lagged but
nothing too bad so it's just afternoon
here I'm about to change my privacy
settings so other people can challenge
me and hopefully that works on me
refresh
we open up the chats hello to people in
the chat hello hi Jose Salam cam
it's a gaga Gingka refika a newness good
to see you guys let's go to the homepage
I'll take challenges if people want to
play me to play someone here to Belgium
novice good to see you sack c90 I'm
still waiting for a challenge no
challenges who's gonna be the first one
I'll accept the first person who
challenges me how about that to reward
the speedy
or maybe no one wants to challenge me
anyone
so lonely right now
send me made puzzles hello interesting
username
well if no one wants to play me uh I can
I can just play someone here I can play
dargah let's play jarda
for challenges
Oh send me may puzzles is
is this your first time watching live
that's exciting
let's play it's by a London I was just
in London yesterday had a very smooth
trip stopped in Iceland
good sushi at the airports okay London
time I'll play c4 and we'll go into the
slide with Queen who he takes what is
taking
on Queen b3 is a threat here
in Queen B 3 is still a fine move attack
the pond trying to induce some weakness
then I'll play Knight c3 now this is 3
plus 1 so
I can't like dirty flat him I'll have to
actually get a good position
alignment off let me fix this alignment
I think the board is too close to the
edge
better slightly better
Kharma
- just trainee with 1e
he plays b6
play Bishop b5
see six
play 903 it's complete development
oh maybe Bishop b5 was a good move
because I had bishop take p8
too late now
I still like my position
good development its Center I have more
center ponds in him maybe someday I'll
play Knight c3 rook e1 in e4
concede the bishop now I have the bishop
here too
you
okay see five thematic move
rook d1 comes to mind this idea comes to
mind
could take and play 95 in some cases
I'm play rook d1 if he takes I take with
rook I avoid any I QP
his night to his Queen and the Queen
doesn't have like a great place to go in
this position
z7 runs into Bishop d6 ideas c7 at some
some point I'll get a trip to c1
okay so he plays Queenie seven I guess
it's playable did I take he takes and
attacks my queen so maybe I play this
is just a pin
and I want to do this and this
listen miss
ah interesting move
back on f4
I really like this bishop it's the only
dark-squared bishop on the board thanks
Toby a 24 the follow
by the way do you guys have any feedback
with my new stream layouts because I've
changed some things tried to make the
board bigger let me know if it is great
or if it's bad always looking for a
feedback I think Bishop a6 is just
really strong because oh because now I'm
trapping a rook Bishop e7
and the rook has to go to d8 button I am
Bishop c7 so White's winning in exchange
check for time
what times do you stream I'm gonna put
together a stream schedule this week
maybe even I'll have it put together
today I haven't had a schedule lately
because I was traveling and it was just
too hectic every day was different but
now for the next three weeks while I'm
in st. Louis I'll have some consistency
so people can find my schedule on my
website there should be a schedule
command to nightbot should deliver with
that f2s attacked forgot about f2 I
could take on e4
I could just trade his queen g4 in some
position
so do I take on e4 do I play g3 or do I
play bishop g3 doesn't make any sense
bg3
[Music]
iconi for two
g4 f3 and rook t2
I still can take and play
Titu
strongest because when I support f3
rook c8
I'm really conflicted here then I take
on a seven
I've wasting so much time okay I'm gonna
play g3
hopefully this doesn't end badly because
my bishop defends from a distance
he's attacking the rook so let's play
play this
his rook is still trapped and there's a
one-second increment which is actually
very meaningful in this sort of
situation because I think I'm just much
better if not close to winning
of time
at once this game is over
anymore time
Knight c3 because okay the Knights are
going to get traded this diagonal will
open up my king will be safe
whoa what does this move it can just
take Bishop g2 is he saving my rook
let's play Bishop d6
rook h1
your kids one
we'll miss it he's probably going to
play Bishop h3
Louie is an IG for coming I think this
is okay
because I have King F 3 if Knight g4
are you sure this is okay his queen is
trapped like kings on f3 where he both
have less than ten seconds left
but I like my situation
she has no moves here
okay interesting game I kind of ended
abruptly he went all out for the attack
I take F 2 and craziness
I think the chess gods were on my side
because I didn't really calculate too
extensively
I just assume this is okay I have this
Bishop b5 move earlier so I realized it
after the fact
I could play Bishop b5 enough c6 I could
take and essentially went upon um yeah
it was probably much stronger and he
would have to play like Knight d7 and
Bishop c6 okay lesson learned to address
people in the chat
hello Tony T 1005 uh I don't think
anyone's shared my schedule hopefully
this works schedule okay
yeah nightbot just gave a link to the
schedule uh okay nice feedback for the
stream layout thank you everyone for the
kind words leek worries thanks for the
comments
my play style over Jerry he plays to
positional I prefer positional chess but
sometimes when I apply online I just get
I get aggressive
is this going on YouTube later this
should be on YouTube later
um
yeah feel free to challenge me I already
have some impending challenges
most of my streams are what is open
challenge what does this even mean
open challenge
from a person
or that's just oh that's to start a new
game
know what this is
I'm curious to accept it though
oh that would know that would enable
like a just a seek
I think I don't want that I've never
seen that before
okay I've Syria by my side give me a
random number between one and eight
syria's mute right now
Siri just started playing music okay
give me a random number between one and
eight seven okay all Brown good luck
you
you
I'm going to play a different opening
unusual
place a similar opening that's what I
usually have been playing this Petroff
lined
now I'm going to try and win as quickly
as possible even if it involves playing
dubious moves
I did someone challenged me and then
just logged off and that's what happened
okay the first dubious move knight c6
I've only learned this recently this is
called the Stafford gambit and it's not
a good opening for black if white is a
strong player but I think it's a very
effective opening if light is like below
16 1700 I think there's just so many
traps
there's many positions where okay box
acts upon very early but gets a lot of a
lot of tactical tricks so I take with
the D pawn I wanted to accelerate my
development and okay we'll see what
happens here I'm gonna play Bishop to c5
I don't think I want to say too much
Bishop c5 is useful move
- maybe ideas of this
control do I prefer anything between
like one minute to
ten minutes I would say
I mean if you want to challenge me it's
a longer game that's okay too because
Syria is just determining my fate
okay
d3 was d3
I think t3s uh it's a natural move but
it allows this move
and that would be
that would be problematic for white
Bhaiji for
okay I haven't studied this Stafford
gambit opening too extensively so I
haven't familiarize myself with all of
the traps but I think this is one of the
traps or white just can't defend f2
unless he wants to play this but then
I'll get initiative
who can I'm on
I wasn't mod someone because there's no
mods in the chats I don't want to be
doing my work while playing
now okay now the question is do I take
with the bishop or the knight because
both seem attractive
tick tick we need to
belike position I should just take with
them bishop or with the Knights and then
keep my bishop
yeah I think that's a
a decision you can kind of use judgments
don't have to rely on calculation
because now these dark squares are just
so weak
till the last game where I I was the
only player with the dark squared Bishop
it's a very powerful situation as you
can essentially control half the board
White has a hard time fighting for these
squares
you
wait cold player 999
- sounds really familiar I think he's
another streamer the other person who I
rated the other day and the other day
like before that too
I was inspired by your layout I think
one of the best we just layout so I've
seen
okay Queen f3 I think I'll play Bishop
thief or unless there's a better move
of age six
do I want to prevent him from castling
queenside or kingside
to Castle queenside I'll play Bishop d4
okay congratulations cold player you
have been awarded the mod title both
player 1992 just because there's no mods
here I usually like to have at least one
mod
in addition I usually have like that at
least one dark sri bishop
such a good bishop
and if you castle this Queen side then
I'm I'm gonna try and go all out to
attack Bishop here Queen here and Queen
here
it's a difficult position for white
because okay this bishops kind of stuck
he could develop it but then you can't
Castle kingside
this Knight is kind of tied down to
defending the pawn
what to do as well
with bishop here
proof
put the ball in whites courts it feels
like tennis just want the ball to stay
in his court gain some time
Queen f4 so he wants to maybe improve
the bishop further well this would be in
my favor because of tactics
let's play Queenie seven
it's a flexible move
keeping him guessing which way I want to
castle
also ideas of this move
Piper thanks for the follow
so he blames my t1 which is actually
probably a decent move defending the
b-pawn and wanting to play c3
isn't there a saying always play up six
it's okay in this
I want to play Bishop e5 with tempo
one key line is that if he plays c3
Bishop ooh he checks me but I can play
g6
that helped them
now I'm gonna Castle queenside Bishop e5
we'll still someday come with tempo and
while I wanted to say that like when he
moves the Queen and threatening d4 I can
play c5 restricting d4 he moves his
Bishop again I can play f5 the center is
about to open up
always have to be cautious when you're
queen or when your king is on the same
file as your opponent's Queen because
now now I have a few options play Bishop
d5 check like Bishop take a to check
this should take f5 check this all these
moves he's probably going to play king
d2
what's the most effective maybe just
bishop take Fi
Roka fades
some initiative
his pieces are 100
cent beef they need to say fresh I do
not get that analogy my pieces feel
fresh I guess
so regards
fit
before
wait a minute he's gonna play King Siwon
and run away
I'm looking for like tactical ways to
stop him like Bishop f6
you can take on a five check
okay I'm gonna start with this
file as his Queen and one rook on the
same file as his King also I have a
donation though weed Urbanski or is it
dahveed
times I struggle with double use thank
you that weed for the a5 wait what did
he do he did something he donated $5
thanks so much
really appreciate that
q it'll wait for the follow
okay so I'm keeping the initiative
attacking this Queen and this King stole
on d2
as Queen is probably gonna move
somewhere a g4 ideally I want to get
Queen g5 even that might be difficult
f-for in
this looks nice
Oh Lord pineapple good to see you back
hello caveman
everyone else so I didn't say hi to
already
own et really likes this color for leech
s okay
this dark color
I get to this should be made very soon
an englis is force made somehow
I guess you could play 93
it's not it's not even force mate thanks
Lord pineapple for your following and
thanks car Mart for the hundred bits
okay time to not get distracted the
knight is pinned
is definitely not for us mates
my work is pinned
I want to play like Queen before I have
an idea I'm gonna play rook e8
idea only works as if he plays a rook
he1
Brooke AE ones better I wanted to play
this and win the rook
be I just play king be it
unpin myself and
Henrick
five
sheiva love thanks for the follow now
low $2.99 mira from argentina nice
to Argentina someday
been to too many like South American
countries am i just winning this so now
I'm up a piece
I still have my darks for a bishop
what to do okay this is my this is my
gun my Alekhine's gun
Sunday are a user to be aggressive
but in reality I might just want to play
queen bee for in this you need him
closer to Zen toss a lot of new names
today good to see some new people I'm
gonna play five great lifts go for the
pawn storm
what is asado Oh is that barbecue
where's that grilled to something ploy
Oh asado is grilled chicken if I'm not
mistaken
Queen G for controlling this
I convert this let's play Queen d6
target the pawn
try and play it a bit quicker too
hello to Jeep to see Yugi
today where am i I'm in st. Louis I was
in London yesterday I was in Prague like
three days ago I was in Spain a couple
of weeks ago
have to adjust to new time zones
is it super dollar dollar sign to travel
the world and play chess it's not as
expensive as you would think I'm very
into like travel hacking and finding
ways to like optimize travels and still
travel like with comforts
now I don't know if too many people know
this but like when you reach the IM
level like if you get if you have like
the IM or GM title you can play in a lot
of international events where tournament
organizers will provide a like hotel or
food so the two European tournaments I
play then we're generous enough to
provide like lodging and breakfast which
makes it a lot more affordable
I'm also very passionate about finding
cheap flights like one of the reasons I
go through London is because it's just
so much so much cheaper to fly through
let's play this
you
so this is okay this position is
completely winning for a black it's just
a matter of trying to win efficiently I
think I want to keep Queens on the board
just
attack
this is not the easiest structure to
break down
but I have some idea now of moving the
bishop in playing rookie 2 and targeting
b2
hmm
messages from so many people I might
have to end soon hopefully not too soon
when I started the stream I was planning
to only stream for like in an hour um
what's my uptime
someone can use up time command I still
don't want to trade Queens
can I convince my eight-year-old student
to not place candy
usually with especially with younger
kids I let them play any opening they
want and just try and give them
resources and openings that they there
student playing
don't want to trade Queens he's being
annoying
let's put the Queen on a6 I'm gonna put
the pawn in a4 and then move the Queen
back to b5 I've only been streaming for
20 28 minutes okay so I guess I'll try
and go for another half hour
I've never been to Finland I've heard
good things about Finland though
not too familiar with each a scene in
Finland
okay let's remove the bishop
forget my queen is attacking me too
brookey one
hey he played for keep on so nice of him
you
yesso is nice to have the queen like far
away and have my bishop far away so
generous
speaking of generous thank-you kalindra
for the sub reciate that
probably just remove the rest of the
mousse
what does all of all this about like
farm-fresh openings I don't understand
but I think 1d 4 equals board games
board games spelled Bo re d
I don't think D for LD 4 as a tendency
to be more positional as you don't
Castle this quickly with E for games you
Castle quicker you attack quicker
okay let's go he mouths lit he mouths it
ouch oh thank you
they're what move email slipped on recap
from this game was nice opening trap the
Stafford gambit like white played two
natural moves yeah d3 is a blunder I
should probably play like Bishop e2 or
Bishop c4
Bishop c4 ones into bishop ticket too so
I should play Bishop e2 here probably
not the easiest move to find
and then the rest of the game was
happiness for black
Oh Queen c1 was a mouse lip made between
d1
yeah that would be all that's still
still crushing for black okay moving on
uh let's play another game
sixteen pending challenges give me a
random number between one and sixteen
nice Persian bishop I got played Persian
bishop before
good luck Persian bishop
18:52 see alive he's alive okay
get to see how boring this d4 opening
will be okay c3 might make it very
boring let's play d5 maybe he'll play a
London this is my t2 we gonna play a
stone wall
there's a funny trap which I'm kind of
tempted to play I'm gonna play e5 here
this is blitz and this is casual I'm
inspired by the Budapest
to play e5 the funny trap is that I
might have a I don't even have a threat
well if he plays this maybe I could play
93
but okay now it's just um it's still
very much Budapest themed I want to win
back the pawn and with upon the d5 I
actually just have a nice will hopefully
have a nice base advantage
let's take the pawn unless like the idea
of 93 is sometimes very powerful but it
only works if Queen h4 check would be
playable
I have some funny idea here of meeting
him in two moves
I'll probably avoid it I would think
you
my cursor get really big
really
someone can clip that because I've
looks normal for me
I don't know yeah we have some kind of
reverse caro-kann type position maybe I
could play Bishop Seif but he's gonna
play III maybe I played g3
or g6 it feels like I'm white here idea
of Bishop g7 and Bishop f5 target is
Queen hello axe villager good to see you
back another mod in the chat
as I get bigger the cursor gets bigger
as well as I get better that cursor gets
bigger don't know if that's true hey
he's playing a floor so he's trying to
open up the center which means I want a
castle as quickly as possible and get
the rook to e1 or to e8 still feels like
I'm white
he's gonna castle soon anyway
I play d4 d4 we trade stuff
ip3
take and then I'm gonna take first he
takes with Bishop I play d4 if he takes
with Knight I can take take and Bishop
f5
and I'm going to try and move quicker
keep forgetting mrs. blitz
hello so what should I name my dog
you dog
you should name your dog after whatever
opening you play
I would name my dog London
or names o or time on earth
or Petrov
what should I name my dog
okay so I have some initiative here this
queen is still a target I'm going to
play this quickly
okay he wants to trade Queens but d3 is
an awkward swerve for the Queen
yes it's playable let's play Queen d7 I
want to play rook d8 he's probably gonna
play this and I'll play this
position name your dog hippo I like that
uh rip t8 first Bishop f5 first
his night is too powerful on g5
toilet noggin welcome back
not the first sighting of toilet noggin
I think it is play Knight e5 oh he wants
to play this
and meet me
I can yeah I can play this and if he
plays this I play this he plays this I
take with check I win this Queen for
free
lacy six defend the pond
he still needs to develop this bishop
can move
this bishops not defended they can't
really punish him for it
I
can
shoved III
93
let's put my work on an open file
I tell my younger students for Exxon
open files have smiles
he's following following the rule
maybe Queens c5
now that hangs up hi
I just don't know what to do here
Brook yet
to open files at some point I'll
probably apply h6
I don't want a seven to be
dead at some point
and there's no increment so
was probably going to be some kind of
time scramble
attacking this pawn let's defend
do this
you
you
I think now it's time to play Knight III
thank Santos season 2 something for the
follow
the goal is to our one goal is this if
he takes and I just had the bishop hair
it should be slightly better for black
I'll answer that question max Phil
and still Gandhi three
do I take
hmm
the rooks defended
wait this is scary my rook is a bit
overworked in some lines
have to do this
if he takes on deer they take with Queen
talking pin myself
okay things are still under control
toilet not gonna eat eating a killer
gyro sounds delicious
wait I'm losing upon
it's man intended
found this pawn
you
that time is going to be a very big
factor
time and initiative
Queen there
this pod is probably just worse here
but if I keep the time advantage it
should be okay also is this just winning
a piece
is f3 in the end
uh-huh this is weird
I have Queen d2 trade
maybe I play rook g5
then
now it doesn't work
you
that's annoying
okay I have to move quicker let's go for
this
after Fagin
five
not
yes Oh in b2
repeat first
you
this is such a bad time scramble
slow
no he's cleaning okay let's put the
Queen there
perpetual now
I
think
you
okay well that was casual that was not
the highest quality game because we both
got low in time I was moving too slowly
I was unfortunate what went wrong
I lost be seven I was a problem I
probably should have played b5 at some
point but then later and I thought he
blundered but maybe it was all planned
out I took too much time here
you
you
yeah I don't know I'm probably gonna
turn on stockfish to see if there's
actual win for her black in this
position but not sure
maybe a rook Tiggy five well I can take
and attack the Queen and have two
bishops
okay analysis board unable analysis
Brook take e5s move
still equal how does it equal tick
we should take take
weenie seven what
he's putting pressure f3 is still a
threat Queen d2 his crazy line that was
this ending
ends with perpetual that's crazy Joanna
try is good to see you my weekend wait
is it the weekend it's Monday it's
Tuesday it was already confused me
yesterday was Monday just lost track of
time
all this traveling
okay let's play another game maybe a
random number between 1 and 17 it's 5
okay
one two three four five was this another
casual game you guys could if you guys
want you can challenge me to rated chess
then a lot of these players will have
the best like the only shot at winning
rating points okay let's play a new
opening let's play let's play g6 a some
kind of appearance modern Magnus lost I
saw he had a difficult position it's
difficult
bosses tournament
is playing the sign with Bishop c4
take on I'm pretty sure I can take on e4
immediately this is one of like these
positional traps and the peer its idea
of Knight a key for or d5 and the center
opens up
actually not entirely sure of the
evaluation of this position but okay
let's not heat the be suckin tongs place
e6 first
team points between favi and magna
swallow and they're gonna play at sync
felled cup in st. Louis it's going to be
exciting
so let's play spring the knight to f6
first
I have a question do people hear the
rain or is my mic just so good that it's
blocking out the background noise it's
raining here and it's getting louder
but I'm using like a very I'm using a
new mic I'm using this professional mic
blue Yeti just found it sitting on the
table
do i tick
really want to take I'll play this move
it runs in tonight g5 maybe I have to
take well just get some equal position
and I'll try and manage my time and if
he takes the Queen I'll be happy is that
I can start minority attacking
oh when you if you hear it when I talk
that's probably because of the sound
filter
I wonder how annoying that is is it
really annoying
called as thunder
I check the sound of my own
which means I should probably keep
talking
also keep playing let's play rook e8
because there's two thematic pawn breaks
in this position a5 and c5 let's put the
rooks in the center I'll probably shift
my Queen to a5
you play as c4 makes my mission much
happier
d4 is less defended maybe double up on
the D file I'm gonna check the stuff
after the game
thunder and lightning
don't remember seeing this in the
forecast
okay I'm going to double up the rooks
maximize the pressure
idea thematic move
upon
probably no reason to play it
maybe the smooth knife each fire
of my left for also unleashing the
bishop
I have two ideas here
you
I'm up on time that's a good sights
you
is it better for the spies a message
blocked
question
I could take on c3 maybe
take on d5 I think I'm winning upon is
it better for the streamer to use free
twitch prime sub or sub manually I think
it's about the same I appreciate all
subs so thanks to everyone who subbed
I think it's it's usually better for
most people to sub for free if you have
twitch Prime
you
okay so I wanna pawn but I just lost
upon now I can win another pawn stick on
c3 with the Queen up upon good position
things are coordinated
d5
bishop
I have a trick in this position I'm
trying to figure out the best way to
execute the trick though
B this is the best way
the trick is that if he takes here I
have Internet so with check
with night at 6:00 I'm attacking two
things I think he's just losing a lot of
things here
at least a piece
I don't see how he defends cuz this is
running into this and I mean I have
Queenie one and end
so in the beef on there like I'm in the
eighth on
okay that was a feel-good sequence of
moves
you
he wants me to play Queen Siwon
force a'queen trade somehow
maybe I just go for meats or go for
flagging
you
I can bring my knight to g3 that's a
cool mating idea
let's try and meet him before he flags
and before he resigns
might be difficult
you
mmm do this
so there's actually a funny trick in
this position
[Music]
I'm sure he was going for
if let's say he plays queen g5 this is
actually a very good lesson for people
because it goes to show why you
shouldn't resign in chess let's imagine
I play one of the most crushing looking
moves Knight g3 if I'm not mistaken
white to move and draw in this position
I'll let four I'll give some time for
the chat to respond I think there's just
an easy draw here
in chat anything important
Skai some hope you would have had hope
if he got to this position
yeah Queen just sacking the queen for a
stalemate
now it's tricky in this position because
the best move for black is probably to
play King f fades
hoping for Queens a got7 that I can take
and unseal mate him but this should
still be a draw here here here
and then
he can take and if here he's gonna sack
the queena
eventually yeah not the hardest puzzled
but useful thing to know in practical
games okay let's move on Marcus Welby
asking why do I prefer a leech s instead
of just calm
I like the leech s interface the fact
that I can share links to games and I
can create collections of games and
studies and they have the built-in like
opening Explorer and table base all for
free but I do occasionally play on chess
back on when they have like their larger
events like the arena kings are
approached s League
but I'm grateful that both sites exist
thanks cold player for the sug they she
ate that hollow streamer
I would encourage everyone to check out
cold player is a well-put-together
stream
okay um it's still raining I might play
one more game let's play another game of
Siri random number between one and
twenty please don't be a long game
please don't be a long game 17 20 19 18
17 we're gonna play this guy legend of
puns I don't have time for 15 plus 15
who's challenging you to the shortest
game we're gonna play toto
minute game
um I just don't have time like today is
a busy day for me there's some lectures
to prepare good luck have fun it's my
move Leiji three
maybe I should be aggressive I'm gonna
go for efore we're gonna play a close
Sicilian set up against a King's pawn
opening play Knight h3
and the whole idea was the salad is to
play f4 f5 g4 g5 and checkmate him
that might be difficult now that he took
but now I haven't open a file I'm gonna
try and bring my knight to the square or
just take in Queen d2
I still want to bring my knight to h5
sack apiece probably and then just lift
the rook I don't care about material I
care about meat
down to minor pieces valign threatening
me than one
oh here's nine of three I guess now I
have to
a good move
maybe I can play this anyway and then
I'll be down a rook but rook g1 is
coming
I'm threatening King eh King H 1 is not
mate but uh he has Queen g5 King H 1
would it be just such a sweet mate um
okay rook take g5 mean I don't think he
had any way out after well maybe after
GT gauge for there some way out I really
wanted to play King H one mates
play that in a game
you
so a question for everyone
can black survive this his white Spratt
is very clear wrote g1 king h1 maybe
there's some way to like give away the
Queen like Queen Queen d7 and then this
toilet noggin thanks for the hundred
bits I play h3 even
three maybe even stronger like Queen d7
King f3 rook g1 would be unstoppable
okay I'll check with stockfish I'm
guessing let me try and guess an
evaluation
you
oh wait no King f3 runs them to Queen
three check
but should still be better for whites I
would say like plus
Queen c7 rook g1
[Music]
trade I'd say plus-one
could be way off could be like +10 let's
see
plus one well I was close plus one point
six plus two point five so what's the
best line kingi three with a computer
move
with his qg3 king g3 actually I guess
keeps all the ideas and prevents between
deep lightning was like that was really
close to here
sure that picked up on audio too
and good to be inside it's good that it
didn't happen while playing a game as I
would that would probably result in the
bad move
so King g3 or h3 I guess f5 this is how
computers play chess King h3 check and
then okay white wins the Queen and it's
a better version of this Queen versus
two rooks okay 58 minutes so I almost
made it to an hour
what can I talk about for one more
minute
okay I know what to talk about there's
something happening right now which is
it's actually being broadcast I think on
me chess and try and find it
streamers
Oh No Oh solty goes streaming
wait is it not featuring the thing wait
a minute
me one moment here I thought they had
like a broadcast now I wanted to promote
the US chess twitch channel but maybe
they're not streaming they are streaming
okay it's just not appearing on me chess
okay so I would encourage everyone
watching to join this raid which one
about to do
um
broadcasts of the US Open tournament
it's happening now features some of the
best players in the US the winner of the
US Open qualifies for US Championships
as a cool tournament because it's one
big open section and a couple friends of
mine are doing commentary and it's
pretty instructive so let me go ahead
and read us chess hello to people who
have just joined
hello Graydon but yeah I'm taking off
see you guys